Okay, how are you?
My name is Alan Drago
, and today I'm going
to tell
you about 10 mistakes
beginner copywriters make and
how to
avoid them in this
video for free.  So before
we get started,
please be sure to
like and
subscribe to the channel
and the video.  This will help
me understand that you
find this content
truly valuable and
want me to
continue
creating content for
free just for
you.  Okay, let's
jump right in and I'll
go over these errors point
by point...in no
particular order.
Find the one you
like.  But the
first one will be number
one.  You don't know
who you're writing to.  This may
be one of the
biggest mistakes
people make: trying to
write for everyone.
Especially in the beginning,
you're not sure who you
're writing to and you just
write the text.  But it
's more important to understand
your target
audience when
you start writing.
Otherwise you don't know
what drives her.  OK?
Copywriting is
more about human
psychology than about the
writing itself.
In fact, Gary
Benson, one of the
most famous
copywriters in the world,
gives an example where
he says, "Think like a
fish, not like a fish or a
human."  OK?
Copywriters often
think like a fish or a
human.  They
are trying to lure
someone onto a hook, not
like a fish.  What do
fish like?  Where do
fish spend their time?  In
what ocean environment do
fish scurry?  Okay, you
have to understand
fish better than
just being a fisherman.
And you'll be able to catch
more fish, because what
is copyright?
You are selling something.  And
if you don't know
who you're selling to, then
you're just writing
content, tweets, and
online posts
that people will like
, which is fine, but
it's not copywriting.
Copywriting is
selling something to someone.
Who are you selling to?
Deal with it.
Problem number two
is the fancy language.
OK?  You will
have to forget
almost everything you
learn in school.
Maybe you were
in middle and high
school and your teacher
told you to write these
long essays with these
thick paragraphs,
multi-syllable
words, a bunch of
adverbs,
adjectives, and
all that.  Well,
these things don't work in the
copyright realm
.  Okay, you
have to realize
that most people
read at a
fourth, fifth,
and sixth grade level.    The
middle level is the
fifth grade level.
So a great
tool that I
used in
the past, I don't
use it anymore,
but I used
it before when I was
just starting out, is
Hemingway.  Okay,
Hemingway will actually
highlight your
sentences and
tell you
what level you're
actually writing at.  And
a lot of people like to
write at an 8th, 9th, 10th
grade level, just to
sound fancy and
sophisticated.  Well, people don't
buy fancy and
fancy.  They
actually buy
stupidly simple things.  That's
what they buy.  So
you need to
simplify your
fancy language and
make it two
syllables, one
syllable.  as much
everyday
language as possible that
your
target audience (
your fish) likes to use, and that's the
best way to
write text.
Rookie mistake
number three is weak
headlines.  Okay,
80% of people read headlines
.  Okay, 80% of people
only read
the headlines and nothing
more.  So only 20%
read the main
text, which means
you need to
spend 80% of your
time creating
that headline.  And
I have a video about
unbeatable
email subjects that would actually
work really well
for writing
headlines.  Whether it's
email subject lines
,
tweet headlines, or
article headlines,
email headlines are a
great way to
write headlines
.  You can
watch this video.
I'll add it to the description
below if you want.
But a weak
headline, without any
compelling words,
without curiosity, without
commitment to its
story, without
specific
information about
who it is
intended for, without
any promise, without
evidence, all this will not
attract the desired
readership.
And in fact, I have a
practice of writing
three to five
headlines for
each topic before
choosing one.  Whether it's
for an
email, a tweet, a
YouTube video like this one, I write
three to five
headlines and say, "
Okay, which one do I
like the most?"  This will
actually help
you write
headlines quickly because you
write a bunch of them for what you
do, and
naturally, you'll
get better over time.
Mistake number four is
copying
competitors in your
industry.  Good.  So,
this headline is very,
very interesting because
I'm actually not against
swiping and
using the
swiping file and
inspiration forms.  But what
newbies often
do is
literally take what
someone else writes, or
take a quote
they have, or a
price they have,
and literally
copy it word for word,
or copy and
paste it into their
own environment, which
, aside from plagiarism, theft,
and
the like, is just a
stupid mistake
because it won't work for
your people.  Again
, this is the mindset
of the fisherman, not the fish.
The person you are writing to is
very different
from the person
other people are writing to.  So when
you use the
word-for-word swipe tactic,
never swipe anyone
directly.  You can
swipe through a
flyer, read it,
enjoy it,
get inspired, and
then figure out what would
work in
your market, in your
industry, and what wouldn't.  And
then apply
your own tactics to make
your people think like
them, like fish,
right?  They are fish.  What do
they like?  Okay
, other people
fish differently.  So
outright "
swiping" won't
work.  Mistake
number five—
never telling a
story.  Good,
especially from behind.
Copywriters
try to provide
value, make promises,
show evidence.
Actually, you should
show more
evidence, but that's all,
right?  You're
trying to
use all the
copywriting frameworks, but you're
not really
telling the story
that
supports
it all, whether it's online on
Twitter, or in
some media, or,
you know, in a sales
letter or an
email.
It's just value,
value, value,
value, value.
Well, value is a
commodity.  OK?
Anyone could collect
value.  If I
wanted value, I could
go to GBT right now and
ask them to find
me 10 books I
should read because
I'm 31, or some
other nonsense they're
publishing right now.  But
telling stories is
unique.
Telling stories
is your personal
business.  In fact,
no one can
change history.
So if you
tell a story
from your life that is
personal to you and you
connect it to
your product, it
makes it much more
powerful because
stories are interesting.  People are
naturally attracted to
them, and they are really
impossible to lure away
.  And so instead of
providing
value, I would
delve into the
storyline.  Problem number
six is
focusing on
the product, not the
problem.  Okay, this
happened to me the other day
.  I got a letter from a
company that
specializes in
lawn care products, and they
sent me something in
the mail, and I opened it
and read this
little brochure because
I have something for my
lawn that I
need to take care of.
I need
thicker grass.  I
have a sundew there.  I have
all sorts of things
just flying
around.  I have
weeds that I need to
take care of.
So I was interested in the
things they were
selling.  I opened
the brochure and all it
talked about was
their product.  We
use different
chemicals.  They
will last you a
while.  They
will work as
if we
are using this
formula, this well-known
formula, and so on.  So,
all that was there was
talking about the
product, but I don't
care about your
product.  Can
you solve my
problem?  This is a very
big part of the fact
that copywriters are often
more interested in
what they are
selling than in the people
they are selling to.  And
this is a big mistake.
Again, we
come back to
this.  Think like a
fish, not like a fisherman.
You need to
focus on
people's problems, not
your product.
Your product is
simply a binary
tool that helps
them solve their
problem.  Because
if you don't solve
the problem or
discuss their
issue, they won't
care about your
product.  Problem
number seven that
novice
copywriters make is
ignoring data.  This is a
huge problem
that I still don't understand.
OK?  It's so easy to
look at your Google
Analytics, look at your
Twitter analytics,
look at your
Medium analytics and
start evaluating what's
working and what's not.
OK?  What headlines
are being read?  Which
products are sold
in which
emails, right?  You
could look at
these things and start to
understand, okay,
people are opening this
headline.  Why do they
open this
headline so much more
often?  Or did people
buy a lot
more from this
email than
from that one?  Why did they
buy so much
more from this
email than
from that one?  OK.  And
some of you will say: “Well
, I don’t have
analytics.  "I'm too
new, or people don't
like my
posts, or, um, people don't
read my
emails."
Yes, there is.  OK.  Every
thing you've
ever published
has analytics, even
if it's just small
analytics.  So if
you tweet once and
most of your
tweets get
one like, but then
you post this
one tweet that
gets two likes.
OK.  Well, it
got 100% more
likes than all your
other tweets.  This
means that
twice as many people like this tweet.
Even if it's just
one or two, it's still
twice as many people.
So there's something about
this tweet or this
email
being opened by 10
more people than the
other five average
people.  OK?
Any data set,
small or large,
will tell you whether something is
working or not.  And the
most important thing you
can do as a
beginner copywriter is to
identify the winners
, identify the
losers, destroy the
losers, and
redouble your efforts
on the winners.
Mistake number eight
— your formatting is
terrible.  This is a serious
problem because
copywriting is like
food.  People eat with their eyes
and read with their eyes.
Of course, they
read with their eyes, but you
know what I mean.
People read
naturally.  So
if you just have
one huge
chunk of text across the entire
page, it's a very
intimidating way to
write text.  This is not
aesthetically pleasing.
Therefore, formatting is
one of the easiest
ways to make your
text more readable.
OK.  Using
H2,
H1, H3 style headings to break up
text.  Using
single
line
spacing to
help break up
the flow.  Using
rhythm, for example, 1
sentence, 3 sentences,
one sentence.  OK?
131, 1315. There are ways to
break up your rhythm to
make your writing
more engaging.
OK?  You can
use
bulleted lists.  You
can
use the
ascending words of
the text, such as long
sentence, medium
sentence, short
sentence.  There are many
ways
to format.
In fact, uh, I'm
proud that so
much of my
formatting could have been
done by
going to all.com,
subscribing to my
daily newsletter,
reading exactly the same way
I format
my
emails all the time.  And so,
you see how I make
even
500 or 1,000 word emails
flow like the waters of Aspen
, right?  You want it to
just shine.
You want people to
just slide down the
page.  In fact,
Joe Sugarman calls
it a slippery slope.
OK?  You want to
make your slide stand out to
people, and formatting
does just that.
Formatting lubricates
the slide so people
slide straight down.
You don't want
them to come down from a
mountain of words.  Okay, that
seems like a lot of
work.  So, your
formatting will give
you much more
time to read.
Mistake number nine
in copyright
is meaninglessness.
Okay,
being meaningless is
one of the most important
things that
novice
copywriters do.  They
just
talk nonsense,
talk nonsense, and they
have all this content there.  And the
truth is,
copywriting is
n't about the more
you write, the better.
In fact, I
literally can't
say anything
less.  Okay, you
have to remember that you
're competing with
attention spans
like TikTok.  People are addicted
to videos on YouTube and
Instagram, and reading
your text can
require a lot of
mental energy.
Therefore, a messy paragraph
can just lose
someone in a split
second.  Therefore, you
should make sure
that each sentence in
your text is a
reason to read the
next one.  OK?  So
you need to
edit ruthlessly
to make sure
you don't have any
meaningless words
that make each
sentence a reason to
read the next.  And
the last mistake that
newbies to
copyright make
is prioritizing features
over benefits.
The most famous example of
this is Steve Jobs
when he released the iPod.  This is the
simplest example of what it is
.
OK.  Around
2003-2004, when he
released the iPod,
everyone had their own
MP3 players, and they were
advertising
things like 1 gigabyte
of memory or 24 hertz,
right?  They
talked about the features of the
product itself.  But
Steve Jobs
turned these
features into
user benefits,
again thinking
about the fish, not the
fisherman.  Okay, what does the
fish want?  What do
your people really want?  Well, they don't
care about 5 gigabytes
or 1 GB of memory.  So
instead of memory, Steve
Jobs said what does it
give them?  It gives them
the ability to store
a thousand songs on
their iPod.  And this iPod is
small enough
to fit in
your pocket, which
turned out to be a very
famous phrase - 1000
songs in your pocket
, which has surpassed all
iPods and all
competitors in
sales.  And therein lies the
power of preference over
function.  If Apple had
just put
5GB of storage in an ad,
no one would
care because it
means nothing to them.  They don't
care about 5 GB of
memory.  But he
wrote 1000 songs in
your pocket.  That's what
worries people.  To carry
music with them wherever
they go and
enjoy that
time.  That's all.  These are 10
copywriting mistakes
for beginners that
you can avoid to
have impressive
copy, sell
more stuff, and
enjoy
your
copywriting career for
decades.  And if
you enjoyed this
video, I ask that you
like the
video and subscribe
to the channel to
let me know that
you want more
free
content like this.  And
finally, before you
go, I have a
free
gift for you if you
haven't received it yet.    The
copywriting catalyst
is in the description
below.  These are 63 copywriting tips
worth learning
every day.  This is a short
lesson that you can
read in 90 seconds
or less.  63 of them to
rapidly increase,
even triple,
quadruple your
copywriting income.  It's
free.  Just
enter your
email address
below and you'll
love it.
Thank you very much, and I'll see
you at the next one.  That
was good.  You want to
use
bonus tip
number 11.
Copywriting mistake that
beginners make.
They talk
about the text more than they
actually write
the text.  That's right.  Hooray.  This is what
simply dominates the Internet.  I
see so many
tweets, copy this,
copy that, my
favorite copywriter
and all that.  But I'm
like: dude, where's your
text?  I don't
like it, are you
publishing the text?  Do
you have the text?  I have never
read any of the texts
you have ever
published.  So how
about you
write some text?
This will help you a lot
.